[Música]
yo pueden visitar a la frontera con
méxico pero aún no no hay fecha
presionado por los republicanos enfrenta
una crisis humanitaria creciente e
intentar gestionar la llegada en aumento
de menores no acompañados el anuncio
llegó en paralelo al incremento de
tropas mexicanas en la frontera con
guatemala
australia de enfrenta las peores
inundaciones en 60 años y anegaciones en
nueva gales del sur con desbordamientos
a las afueras de citi unas 18.000
personas ya fueron evacuadas y se espera
que continúen las precipitaciones este
lunes tenemos reporte desde melbourne
es el día mundial del agua la
conmemoración oficial instaurada por
naciones unidas- está dedicada a generar
conciencia sobre un recurso vital cada
día más escaso para el 2025 se calcula
que dos tercios de la población mundial
sufrirán el desabastecimiento tenemos
análisis de la situación en la región
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante de américa
latina y del mundo bajo la lupa está la
crisis migratoria en la frontera entre
eeuu y méxico el presidente joe biden
tiene previsto visitarla ante el aumento
de la llegada de inmigrantes
indocumentados el anuncio llegó en
paralelo al incremento de tropas
mexicanas en la frontera con guatemala
por su parte del ex presidente de donald
trump o lo acusó de crear un desastre
nacional matías árabes nos amplía la
frontera está cerrada a la defensiva y
acusada de provocar la afluencia de
miles de emigrantes la administración de
joe biden estuvo este domingo en todos
los frentes tratando de tranquilizar a
la gente sobre su capacidad para manejar
la primera gran crisis de su presidencia
estamos en el proceso de hacerlo ahora
incluso asegurándonos de restablecer lo
que existía antes que era que podían
quedarse en su casa y presentar su caso
desde su país de origen byd en que
anunció que viajará en algún momento a
la frontera se ha enfrentado a las
críticas de los republicanos por su
gestión el gobierno de bailén ha tenido
problemas para albergar al creciente
número de menores no
a dos que viajan solos desde
centroamérica son más de 14.000 niños
niñas y adolescentes que están en
custodia por parte de las autoridades
estadounidenses específicamente bajo el
cuidado del departamento de salud y
servicios humanos y otros por la oficina
de aduanas y protección fronteriza
alejandro mayorkas secretario de
seguridad nacional reconoció que se
esperaba una afluencia histórica de
migrantes la mayor en 20 años en la
frontera sur sin embargo llamó a los
migrantes centroamericanos a no venir
por ahora lo que el presidente se ha
comprometido y lo que yo me comprometo y
ejecutó es asegurar que tenemos un
sistema de inmigración que funciona y
que la migración a nuestro país es
segura ordenada y humana en gmail ante
el anuncio de bailén de ir a la frontera
el ex presidente donde el tren lo acusó
de haber creado un desastre nacional y
reivindicó su legado afirmando que
entregó al gobierno de byd en la
frontera más segura de la historia e
instó a reanudar la construcción del
muro en la frontera con méxico
en otros temas australia se enfrenta a
las peores inundaciones en 60 años al
noreste de sydney se desbordaron los
ríos hotspur iu y pp han causando graves
inundaciones las lluvias de los últimos
tres días tienen a la región de nueva
gales del sur en estado de emergencia
obligando a evacuaciones masivas de unas
18.000 personas se espera que las
precipitaciones continúen este lunes
desde melbourne nos envió el reporte con
los detalles nuestro corresponsable de
camilo montoya
según la agencia de meteorología de
australia se trata de inundaciones no
vistas en el país desde 1961 hace 60
años se concentran principalmente en el
estado de nueva gales del sur cuya
capital es sídney pero también están en
alerta a otros estados de la costa de
este australiana como lo son queensland
y también este el estado de victoria
cuya capital es melbourne es decir que
10 de los 25 millones de habitantes que
tenía australia están bajo el riesgo de
esta tormenta la magnitud de esta
tormenta según lo han dicho los expertos
es equivalente al tamaño de alaska o de
300 millones de canchas de fútbol los
organismos de emergencia han hecho más
de 700 rescates se han recibido ocho mil
llamadas de auxilio y las inundaciones
han afectado carreteras viviendas y
también cultivos mientras miles de
personas siguen siendo evacuadas y
tratan de salvar sus pertenencias el
gobierno federal ha anunciado ayudas
económicas para los afectados lo
preocupante es que las lluvias van a
seguir por los próximos tres días y solo
hacia el miércoles o jueves empezarán a
hoy se cumplen 5 años de los ataques
suicidas en bruselas que dejaron 32
personas muertas e hirieron a más de 340
en el aeropuerto nacional y en una
estación de metro cerca de la sede de la
unión europea los reyes de bélgica y el
primer ministro alexander de croo
participaron primero en los actos de
homenaje a las víctimas y sobrevivientes
del ataque yihadista de 2016 en el hall
del aeropuerto de zaventem en bruselas
posteriormente se desplazaron hacia el
punto donde ocurrieron los actos de
terror cerca de la sede europea los
atentados fueron perpetrados por la
célula yihadista franco-belga que ya
había atacado en parís el pasado
noviembre el juicio iniciará en
septiembre de 2022 y aunque falta tiempo
las víctimas de bruselas se han estado
preparando para esta experiencia durante
varios meses
[Música]
en 5 años cristian ha vuelto muy pocas
veces a este barrio cercano a las
instituciones europeas con el tiempo las
marcas de quemaduras apenas son visibles
en su rostro pero el recuerdo sigue ahí
el 22 de marzo de 2016
cristian estaba a cuatro metros del
atacante que se inmoló en el metro cerca
a esta estación
todavía hoy despierta muchos
sentimientos cuando el metro se cerró y
se puso en marcha se produjo la
explosión la explosión y el juicio no
está previsto para antes de septiembre
de 2022 sin embargo christian ya se está
preparando se tomará unos días libres
para seguir esta audiencia
extraordinaria que debería durar entre
seis y nueve meses
como queremos entender como los
terroristas pasaron de la radicalización
a la acción
[Música]
a la chs la comprensión se ha convertido
casi en una obsesión para philippe en
preparación para el juicio esta víctima
incluso tomó cursos legales en ese
momento mi vida está en suspenso y
realmente estoy esperando esta prueba
para poder seguir adelante es
prácticamente el único objetivo en mi
vida en este momento pero el proceso es
difícil para las víctimas sobre todo
porque desde el atentado se sienten
agraviados por el estado
es sumamente complejo para las víctimas
tener una compensación efectiva están
deambulando entre el fondo de asistencia
las compañías de seguros los distintos
organismos que intervienen y realmente
es muy injusto a diferencia de francia
donde los casos de terrorismo son
juzgados por magistrados profesionales
bélgica recurre a un clásico tribunal de
lo penal el fiscal federal ha pedido en
repetidas ocasiones la destitución del
jurado popular para juicios tan grandes
entre tanto la fecha precisa de este
histórico proceso debería conocerse en
junio
este lunes se celebra el día mundial del
agua instaurado por la organización de
naciones unidas la gestión del agua se
ha convertido en un desafío determinante
para los países una situación que se
agrava con el calentamiento global de
acuerdo con naciones unidas- dos tercios
de la población mundial vivirá una
escasez de agua en 2025
para analizar es el agua un recurso
indispensable que año tras año se torna
más escaso en la actualidad cerca de un
cuarto de la población mundial se
encuentra en lo que se conoce como
situación de estrés hídrica grave
numerosas actividades humanas provocan
la sequía que reduce el agua dulce del
planeta regiones que alguna vez fueron
fértiles como andalucía en el sur de
españa se transforman poco a poco en
desiertos y las tensiones entre países
se hacen notorias un ejemplo se da en
torno al río nilo fuente esencial para
una decena de países en áfrica del este
la gran presa del renacimiento lanzada
en 2011 por etiopía suscita todavía
inquietudes en sudán y egipto ambos
países dependientes del río temen ver
limitado el acceso a sus aguas la misma
tensión la comparten jordán líbano
israel siria y jordania que se disputan
el control del agua mientras el río
jordán se seca y el consumo de los
países aumenta
en asia la sequía del río mekong y la
multiplicación de empresas chinas
amenazan directamente a 60 millones de
habitantes en los últimos años e incluso
grandes ciudades como roma los ángeles o
ciudad del cabo se han visto amenazadas
por sequías según la onu 3600 millones
de personas viven en zonas
potencialmente pobres en agua
para analizar este tema nos acompaña
desde washington sergio campos el jefe
de la división de agua y saneamiento del
banco interamericano de desarrollo
gracias por acompañarnos y comienzo
preguntándole veíamos en el informe un
panorama mundial de los países
amenazados por las sequías como esta
américa latina y el caribe en materia de
agua y de saneamiento
buenos dias angela un saludo a toda la
audiencia de francés tony ford
bueno la sector latinoamericano está
exenta de los desafíos que tiene el
mundo el cambio climático nos recuerda
la importancia de tener instrumentos
este adecuados nuestros países durante
los últimos 20 años han hecho un
progreso importante en dotar de acceso a
agua y saneamiento a nuestra población
pero ese es un progreso que todavía es
insuficiente y en nuestra región al 2015
todavía había más de 19 millones de
personas que dejaban al aire libre más
de 34 millones de personas que no tienen
acceso a agua potable y más de 106
millones de personas que no tenían
acceso a saneamiento adecuado cuando
nosotros nos medimos con una meta o con
una vara mucho más estricta como la de
las metas de desarrollo sostenible hay
más de 450 millones que no tienen un
manejo adecuado de las excretas y hay
más de 200 millones de personas que
tienen no tienen acceso al servicio de
agua potable o un servicio continuo no
este si uno piensa esos números en
términos de combatir la pandemia de la
verdad la pandemia nos agarra
desprevenidos y cuando nosotros vemos
cuáles son los principales desafíos el
principal desafío es acceso tenemos que
asegurar que esos dos siguientes
millones de personas tengan acceso a o
potable esas 450 millones de personas
tengan acceso a manejo de excretas hay
hay mucho trabajo que hacer en el
tratamiento de las aguas residuales
cuando uno camina por latinoamérica en
la mayor parte de los patios urbanos no
es poco común ver las excretas esté
siendo dispuestas por las formas veredas
entonces esos son los grandes desafíos
el junto con eso viene una financiación
es infraestructura necesita ser
financiada también tenemos temas de
gestión gobernanza dentro de las
empresas
sergio experiencia que la interrumpa
imperios técnicos pero es que quisiera
hacerle más preguntas para que nos
alcance el tiempo
usted nos estaba hablando de las
excretas que no es un panorama poco
usual ver que no se dispone bien de
ellas usted cómo cree que va el trabajo
por mejoramiento del manejo de aguas
residuales en la región
mire toda latinoamérica todavía trata
únicamente el 25 de las aguas residuales
que se generan hay mucho trabajo por
hacer el impacto en el ambiente es
importante hay mucha gente que en la
migración del campo a la ciudad este se
asienta en lugares informales y en áreas
muy vulnerables estés cerca a ríos o
cerca de cuerpos hídricos para poder
tener acceso que están visiblemente
contactados miren este es un tema que
nos da para conversar mucho más tiempo
espero que podamos tener la oportunidad
en otro espacio gracias a usted y
continuamos con más noticias el segundo
tribunal popular intermedio de beijing
se realizó a puerta cerrada del juicio
contra el segundo canadiense michael
djokovic por ahora no se conoce la fecha
en la que se entregara el veredicto
china de restaba kobrich e y también a
su compatriota canadiense michael es
favor en diciembre de 2018 acusados de
espionaje poco después de que la policía
canadiense detuviera am en guangzhou
directora financiera del gigante
tecnológico chino huawei con una orden
judicial estadounidense desde beijing y
nos envió un informe con los detalles
corresponsal adrián foncillas
michael kubrick ha sido juzgado en un
tribunal pequinés por espionaje sólo
tres días después de que su compatriota
michael es favor fuera juzgado por el
mismo delito ambos fueron detenidos hace
más de dos años y medio y sus juicios se
han desarrollado a puerta cerrada sin
acceso de periodistas extranjeros ni
diplomáticos porque asegura china que el
caso está relacionado con secretos de
estado el caso de los michael ha llevado
las relaciones diplomáticas a su punto
más bajo canadá habla de juicio político
de diplomacia de rehenes y ha exigido su
liberación inmediata a la detención de
los michaels llegó apenas unos días
después de que fuera arrestada en canadá
menguan joe la heredera del imperio
tecnológico huawei a petición de la
justicia estadounidense en men sigue en
arresto domiciliario en vancouver
esperando a que se resuelva su proceso
de extradición y china ha desmentido que
los dos casos estén relacionados el
horizonte de los 2 mickael es sombrío
porque la justicia criminal china
registra más de un 99 por ciento de
sentencias condenatorias así que su
liberación
por un acuerdo diplomático
y es momento de ver lo que publicamos a
esta hora en nuestro sitio web e
france24 punto como usted puede leer con
hoteles sobre deportación en eeuu
insiste en que su frontera no está
abierta a la inmigración y en mi armar
al menos cinco manifestantes fallecidos
y dos australianos detenidos este fin de
semana durante las protestas también al
menos 22 civiles fueron asesinados en un
ataque contra tres aldeas en el sur de
níger al momento se actualiza que ya
serían hasta 40 personas fallecidas
y así llegamos al final del informativo
usted continúe con nosotros en france 24
buenos días
[Música]